hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing with in
1858 clash between Paul Charles Murphy
and Thomas Wilson Barnes after that
first game does Morphy 1 we are now
continuing with another game where
Murphy had the white pieces because as
you've seen so far in the Murphy saga
that's how they did it in those days you
get two y's then you get two black so
something something weird but it is the
way it is so in this game Murphy again
opens with E 4 but we have a bit of a
different opening so a Barnes goes for
e5 we have 9 of 3 and now d6 going for
philidor's defense we have d 4e captures
and now Bishop to c4 not going for
Knight character sandy 4 which could
could kind of be also good I mean it is
the way to go but in those days you
would play some like Bishop c4 you would
play C 3 gambit this point maybe gambit
this point as well and get a lot of
rapid development so Barnes continues
with Bishop to e7 and c3 now he offers a
upon but Barnes declines it with d3 with
the idea of hindering the development of
White's pieces so you will either play
Queen cat first or Bishop captures and
you don't want either of those to be
under d3 square so Queen to b3 now
putting pressure on the f7 square also
under on the b7 square and now Bishop to
e6 by Barnes now offering up the b7 pawn
and it is a it is kind of a good idea by
Barnes because if you cover something
like Queen captures and then of course
the rock hang so 97 and then you try to
pick up the d3 pawn you could also
capture here which is what happened in
the game but if you go for something
like Bishop captures on b3 then 95 with
a double attack here you have to go for
Queen b5 check c6 Queen captures on c6
check and now after King f8 okay you did
get some material but black got a lot of
development in rook b8 is coming Knight
is attacking the bishop here and it's
just just a nice position for black so
more free more fee goes for a similar
idea but not quite the same he goes for
captures captures and only now captures
Knight to d7
India after Queen captures on b7 this
has never been reached again so
tonight's the d7 by Barnes in now Queen
to b5 the Queen needs an escape route
and also you kind of want to get rid of
this pawn here so nice to have six
putting pressure on the e4 pawn asking
what do you want to do now you could
capture on d3 right away but then you
allow the knight to come to c5 with
tempo so more if he leaves that for some
other time he goes for the e6 pawn which
is which is weak so he goes knife to g5
he goes for this pawn and we have roped
the b8 Barnes goes after Murphy's Queen
on b5 we have Quinta a4 and now mr.
Barnes the madman goes for castles he
gives up the e6 pawn and we get to the
position from the thumbnail why did he
allow such a thing well of course a
morphic captures it but now he goes for
Knight the c5 working morphus Queen and
also the knight and e6 and now if you
trade Queens for example characters
captures and now if the knight has to go
back let's say 96 now after the rook
moves it's actually a very good position
for black black still has a passed pawn
here there's a double attack on the beat
upon the e4 pawn is hanging so Barnes is
definitely on to stun to something here
so after this night to see five more
feet asides okay let's not trade Queens
let's just trade nights here but then
captures captures and now you still have
the very strong d3 point you still have
the the CC pawn which if you can get to
see for this will be an incredibly
strong passport so Queen the c4 check by
morphe King to a trait and only now does
morphe castle but now Knight to g4 and
already you can see that Barnes has some
very very tricky ideas like it's very
hard to develop this Bishop it's very
hard to develop the knight if you if you
block block the night with the bishop
then a lot of things again are possible
now you know this diagonal is no longer
covered maybe you can get some rooks
into the attack maybe the Queen can come
into the attack and the knight also
helps out it's just a very pleasant for
position for blacks so morphe
immediately goes for f4 he blocks this
diagonal and prepares to push a 5 f5 and
so on and here a barnes could just
continue with normal development Queen
d6 puts pressure on the h2 paneer so
morphine
I cannot push f5 right away but instead
mr. Barnes decided to play in great
style as he did you know so far so he
goes for d2 he gives up a pawn but the
problem is if Murphy captures with the
bishop then we'll capture Sun be too if
he captures with the knight then the
bishop no longer covers d3 square and
let safe night characterize 93 just goes
for a nice fork here so after this d2
more if we decided to go for Bishop
captures on D - but now rook captures
and b2 by Barnes and now morphe says ok
you are attacking my bishop here twice
but first I'm gonna play h3 I want to
get rid of this night so you don't have
nice - III at all but Barnes says nope
I'm still I'm still going for that he
goes for rook captures on d2 he removes
the defender of the III square more he
recaptures and only now Knights - III
again with a nice fork so this is a this
is a very crazy game we have Queen back
to e to buy more fee and only now barns
three characters on f1 so rook captures
and now Queen to d7 and now we get this
position we're more fizz up a pawn and
Barnes Barnes doesn't have a lot to show
for it he has a CC pawn he does have a
bishop against tonight but it's not not
a not a star bishop or anything so it
was a crazy game but in the end it seems
that the the resulting well sort of end
game is in more fees favor so nice the
c-4 by Murphy and we have Queen to b5
now now the Knights cannot move as the
Queen would hang here and E 5 more FINA
wants to go he 5f5 Queen Queen h5 twin
g4 and create an attack against the
black King so brush up the h4 year by
Barnes and more features continues
pushing f5 with Bishop back to e7 Barnes
is waiting to see what Murphy will do
and now Queen the g4 getting the Queen
away from the pin but also keeping an
eye on the knight on c4 so Queen back to
d7 and now comes a rook to d1
attacking Barnes Queen and now comes
Queen captures on f5 Murphy gives up the
pawn but he will get the rook to d7 so
it's not a problem
so Queen captures on f5 will route
on f5 n now rook to d7 attacking the
bishop and the pawn and here Barnes just
goes back with Bishop the fate however
this is not enough to hold hold a whole
Morphy off so feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the absolute
best and quickest way for Morphy to win
the game while i give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on noticing
that passed pawns must be pushed and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show it's of course II 6 now the point
is the rook cannot go behind the pawn as
the night covers that Square and you
cannot go to f7 to guarded the e7 score
so whatever you do a 7 is coming and
that's just it
you don't have a way to save your bishop
if you move your Bishop let's say you
try Bishop to d6 at the present for it
not to be captured just characters
characters and this is just made there's
not much to be done about this so here
after this c6 move well there's nothing
nothing more to be done here and it was
also in this position on move 29 that
Thomas Wilson Barnes resigned the game
as after any move east 7 is coming and
that's just it captures captures you're
down a piece and of course in a
completely lost endgame so a very good
game by both of them even though more if
you want you can see that the Barnes is
not another pushover he he can really
you know whole hold his own against
Morphy in any tricky combinations but in
the end the the resulting endgame was
just much more favorable to morphe so
that's the second game we've covered
from the match I do hope you enjoyed it
I also invite you to check out the song
about morpheme by our own page it will
be the first link in the description
below he already made one song about a
lot of just general if you remember
maybe a year ago now he strikes back
with a song about Paul Morphy so do
check it out it's a very very enjoyable
I would also like to thank Luis Serra
pelada Segura
Thomas Thomas called Michael Buckley
Christopher sirata and Peter Killian for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous video serie
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
continuing the good stuff checking up on
you
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day